I want you to tell all your friends
about me one of the most iconic
characters in comic book history is
celebrating a milestone 80 years ago
today Batman made his very first
appearance in Detective Comics number 27
it came out on March 30th 1939 and a
multibillion-dollar bat industry was
born
Batman has had a huge impact on popular
culture not just in comic books but in
movies television shows cartoons video
games toys roller coasters I think
there's probably Batman fruit snacks you
name it Batman has done it
that very first Batman issue was the
work of artist Bob Kane and writer bill
finger commissioned by DC to create a
new superhero to build on the success of
Superman like the Man of Steel the Caped
Crusader also had a double life
millionaire playboy Bruce Wayne by day
Batman by night oh well you took my
advice about theatrical a bit through
the decades the Dark Knight picked up a
sidekick
Robin the Boy Wonder and first came to
life on the silver screen in a 1943
movie serial
[Applause]
the 1960s brought yet another caped
incarnation that can't be character of
the Batman TV show what's wonderful
about the Batman show was the creators
of that show deliberately set out to
make a kind of comedy of Batman they
looked at this guy this incredibly
wealthy guy who spends all his time
running around in pajamas Batman pajamas
fighting crime and said this is
ridiculous we should make something that
embraces and celebrates how ridiculous
it is
in 1989 Batman came back to the big
screen and over the years has been
played by five different actors over the
course of nine films grossing in the
billions every one for Michael Keaton
Val Kilmer George Clooney why are all
the gorgeous ones homicidal maniacs sue
Christian Bale and Ben Affleck but all
the while Batman stayed true to his
origins on the pages of the comic books
that brought him to life 80 years ago
today a favorite man Adam West
always always that's the popular Joe
happy brutally Batman you